because of the work that I've done on
these issues protecting women and girls
I have heard from people about
scholarships academic competitions I've
heard about Job promotions we have even
had cases in women's prisons and
domestic abuse shelters where someone
presents and says they're a female or
they identify as female so you're so
correct on this it is something that is
becoming an issue in so many different
areas of our society and people want to
make certain that their what they have
fought for the rights the opportunities
they have fought for as a woman that
those are recognized and that they are
not disadvantaged
foreign
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the senior U.S senator from the great
state of Tennessee and somebody who
actually knows what a woman is how Wild
Senator Marsha Blackburn welcome to the
Reuben report it is good to be with you
thank you so I want to start right there
you know what a woman is and not only do
you know what a woman is you've asked
other people in this case then uh
Supreme Court nominee katanji Brown
Jackson you asked her what a woman was a
couple months back in a very viral clip
so I want to throw to that and get your
thoughts can you provide a definition
for the word woman
can I provide a definition no yeah
I can't
you can't
not in this context I'm not a biology
meaning of the word woman is so unclear
and controversial that you can't give me
a definition senator in my work as a
judge what I do is I address disputes if
there's a dispute about a definition
people make arguments and I look at the
law and I decide so I'm not the fact
that you can't give me a straight answer
about something as fundamental as what a
woman is underscores the dangers of the
kind of progressive education that we
are hearing about
well Senator uh did you expect that sort
of response
you know I did not and when you look at
the full line of questioning I started
with the school board she serves on and
the fact that they have awoke
kindergarten a curriculum did she
support that she said she didn't know
about it so I asked her about Virginia
and VMI and that case made it to the
Supreme Court U.S versus Virginia
and that is the decision that was
written by Ruth Bader Ginsburg that
allowed women into our military
academies and it's kind of law school
first year so I asked if she agreed with
Ginsburg and her writing and gave her
that quote and said it basically said
women and men have enduring differences
well she said she had never heard of the
case
and was unfamiliar with the writing I
didn't think that sounded quite right so
I asked her to define the word woman and
she refused to do so as we've seen and I
did that because I was trying to get to
men in women's sports and the impact
that is having on young women and just
like U.S versus Virginia I know that at
some point what the NCAA has done with
allowing men in women's sports there
will be lawsuits and that will make its
way to the Supreme Court so I wanted to
see where she was on it and Dave you
know the interesting thing I met
privately with her
before we did our hearings I laid out
for her when we met privately uh what I
was going to ask her about when we did
go into the hearing we had a delightful
discussion we met for about an hour uh
we went through a series of things and I
was very fair pointing out what I was
going to ask then when we did our
opening statements on Monday prior to
the hearing beginning on Tuesday I again
went through a recitation
listing the things I was going to
discuss with her in the committee
setting so she knew what was coming but
she chose not to give me an answer and
everyone knows that there are
differences between men and women and I
think everybody could give me a
definition of a woman an adult female
uh two X chromosomes I I think that you
know there are plenty of ways that this
could be answered saying I am a woman uh
these there are ways to answer that so
it just shows you how far the left is
pushing even members of the U.S Supreme
Court to deny that there are differences
between male and female you know I hate
to play the identity politics game but
but for you as a female senator asking
this question how concerned are you now
that as these cases rise up to the
Supreme Court that they will not have a
foundational definition of woman and as
you say we will have I mean we already
have it we will have men beating women
in Collegiate swimming in wrestling in
basketball et cetera et cetera and
although it's just in some sense people
think oh well that's just about sports
it's actually about something much
bigger happening in society right now
well it is and because of the work that
I've done on these issues protecting
women and girls I have heard from people
about scholarships academic competitions
I've heard about Job promotions uh we
have even had cases in women's prisons
and domestic abuse shelters where
someone presents and says they're a
female or they identify as female so
you're so correct on this it is
something that is becoming an issue in
so many different areas of our society
and people want to make certain that
their what they have fought for the
rights the opportunities they have
fought for as a woman that those are
recognized and that they are not
disadvantaged so we're going to continue
to stay on this issue and continue to
support women and girls as they work to
preserve the opportunities that should
be there for them one more on this and
then we'll get to some other stuff do
your colleagues on the other side of
this issue did you know generally
Democrats consider themselves feminists
so that means that they would you know
be for women in in some sense do any of
them when you talk to them privately say
boy we've we've really kind of lost the
ball on this one and we're actually
defending men who you know purport to be
women let's say and that but it's it's
sort of gone too far the whole party has
gone so radical there's not much that
they can do
you know one of the interesting things
to me has been how women on the left
will all fall in line behind whatever
the left says is their agenda for women
and they stay very close to that they're
very submissive to the left's agenda on
gender about when you have conservative
women or women that are center right or
to the right what do you hear they will
come at you and will absolutely blast
you and say oh you're not a real woman
oh you're not defending women if you
don't fall in line and submit to that
agenda to the left it is a very
interesting Dynamic that is happening
and these leftist groups they don't show
up to protect women who are conservative
so I saw you a couple weeks ago you were
kind enough to take a few minutes in
your office right after the midterms and
obviously the Red Wave did not fully
form the way a lot of people thought and
and when we were chatting they were
still trying to figure out even if the
Republicans were going to get Congress
which obviously did happen are you
hopeful now that there's going to be
some actual change here I mean I think a
lot of people and I know this from my
own audience they're they're happy that
the Republicans got Congress but there's
always this feeling like ah they got it
but they can actually do anything
and one of the frustrations for so many
tennesseans that I talked to is that you
have Republicans who will not back
Republican principles and they want them
to focus on getting the government
spending under control securing that
southern border making certain that
crime is addressed that we work to get
drugs off the street and support law
enforcement those are the things that
people are wanting to see addressed and
they're very concerned that you will
have some Republicans in the house since
I'm in the Senate that won't support
getting things done for the American
people I fully believe that this next
two years is a great opportunity for
Republicans to show what we are for and
to draw that distinction between what
Democrats are for and what Republic
answer for it's a great opportunity for
us we should embrace that and we should
be bold so are you hopeful that the
Congress will do it obviously you don't
have as much leverage in the Senate but
do you think that that the whoever ends
up as the leader and whatever whatever
Direction they go will be the right one
My Hope Is that you're going to see
House Republicans and Senate Republicans
work together to stop a lot of these bad
initiatives that are coming out of the
White House and we need to be sure we we
don't make life difficult for one
another but that we stay focused on
things a few things that the American
people want to see done the spending the
crime the Border making certain we fund
the military making certain that we're
protecting our families let me ask you a
little bit about your home state of
Tennessee because Tennessee much like
Florida where I am now is is absolutely
booming and I told you I considered
Nashville it almost happened but a lot
of my friends have moved there as you
know daily wire has moved down there
there's really like a real explosion in
Tennessee right now are you guys just
feeling good about things like we're
doing it right we're seeing this influx
and and it's all good
yes but bear in mind this has been a
long time in the making getting
Tennessee on the right path I when I was
in the state senate there was a big push
and it was a four-year battle four full
years uh we had a governor that was
pushing a state income tax and I led
that opposition we kept our state income
tax free we're never going to have a
income tax in Tennessee because we've
amended the State Constitution that
doesn't allow it what that is what was
the argument for it it seems so hard for
me as a former Californian to come to
Florida where I'm paying no income tax
the idea that anyone here would say yes
we would like income tax here yes it
just sounds so insane yes and uh
Tennessee in the mid 90s had been the
test case for Hillary Clinton's health
care and it was a program TennCare it
was to cost two billion dollars a year
but with any government-run program they
always underestimate they're building it
on Theory and it never works never works
and it was an eight billion dollar
program so after that five years of
experimentation they decided oh wait a
minute we've got to have money to pay
for this thing oh we don't have an
income tax Let's do an income tax and
pay for this program well as you know
working on symptoms is not always the
right thing to do you have to go to the
root cause and the root cause was the
program did not work and passing an
income tax was not going to fix the
broken program but Dave you know it was
really wonderful people of the state
supported me in that effort to fight
that facts it's the people of the state
of Tennessee who stood up they stood
with me and we were able to defeat that
tax and Tennessee is better for it we
are a well-managed state we're
considered one of the top
one or two three
well-managed states in the country we
have the lowest tax burden we have our
secretary of state and the state was
recently honored our state is number one
in election Integrity those are things
that people want to see so when you've
got that great quality of life a
well-run state low cost of doing
business a good standard of living
that's where people want to come does
does it shock you the Stark difference
now between a well-run state and a
poorly Run State I mean I can always
bring everything back to to California
but you know the fact that you have to
show an ID to vote in Tennessee or in
Florida and you don't in California I
mean are you shocked that it they're
just continuing to go down that path
ballot harvesting et cetera et cetera
you guys closed your polls and I think
you had one basically immediately that's
right and when you talk about poor
management of States I always think I I
was listening to something on California
the other day you know they're going to
increase their state income tax and
they're trying to pass a bill that if
you leave California yeah and you've
built your business there for 10 years
they're going to tax you and I it
reminded me of that great country song
written by James Dean Hicks it's called
the whole and the jest of the song is
when you're in a hole stop digging and
so you know Dave some of these uh States
need to learn that lesson whether
they're New York or Illinois or uh
California or Washington State just give
it up give it up and try to start fixing
the problems that are affecting you
Unfortunately they really like that
shovel apparently yes they do and they
just keep digging what kind of stresses
do you guys have with such an influx do
you know how many people have come to
Tennessee over the last two or three
years I mean it's it's got to be my
guess is it's got to be at least a
hundred thousand right well the the
number continues to grow and I think in
the Nashville area they are changing
about a thousand driver's license and
car tags uh every single week wow and it
doesn't matter where I go whether it's
to church or the grocery store or one of
the kids activities I'm meeting people
who have relocated to Tennessee from
California and from New York and many
other places some of these big blue
States Connecticut
Illinois and they finally they say you
know we've just had it we can't handle
it anymore I was talking with someone
from New York and they said they left
New York City they're in the financial
service sector we've had a couple of big
look relocations coming out of New York
City to Nashville and they said they
they have small children and they
thought you know we can work from
anywhere and they had started here's
what did it
they were trying to get their child into
a preschool and they were told by
somebody well you need to hire a
consultant to coach your child to get
into a free school because there are so
few good preschools that are available
that are not into the woke kindergarten
woke education things of that nature so
uh the this family said after they heard
all of that they said we need to move
and so they came to Tennessee have you
guys done anything like Governor
DeSantis is doing here in Florida
related to making sure that the the woke
stuff doesn't get into the schools oh
yeah and in all of our institutions yeah
yes uh they had passed Tennessee has
passed a ban uh they don't allow the
teaching of CRT they've changed people
that are on the textbook commission uh
they go through a different review
process
they will not allow the woke curriculums
to take place they are dealing when they
go back in in January my understanding
is they are going to deal with some of
the gender dysphoria issues and the way
that is
represented to minors and the allowance
what has been the allowance by some of
surgeries or medications that deal with
the gender dysphoria issues
what uh what are you planning uh related
to covid if if they start you know quote
unquote bringing covet back or if
there's a surge and all this stuff you
know we're hearing that La it's like
always you know a half inch away from
bringing back masks I mean what can you
guys do to ensure that that tennesseans
can live the way they wish and make
choices for themselves well and and we
know that fearful people are easier to
control
that was one of the reasons that you had
pushing the lockdowns and the mandates
during covet and you have some is Dr
fauci is being ushered out the door he
is a very defiantly saying we may have
to go back to lockdowns and mandates and
I think people are saying we're over
that uh the science it didn't support
that they are looking at the learning
loss and the mental health issues of
children from the masking and the
lockdowns and the isolations and they're
also looking at people who have the
vulnerabilities and or more susceptible
to covet or any other type disease and
Dave I think that you know whenever the
next pandemic comes that people will be
smarter about this and interestingly
enough they're probably going to be less
trustful of government and what
government is telling them and what
we're finding out from the Twitter files
and
other things you're going to see how you
had uh Elite Democrats and federal
agencies and people working together on
what they classified as disinformation
and what they allowed to be put out as
information and now what is it that
we're finding out it's probably flipped
the things that they were saying was
disinformation was actually correct yeah
are you doing anything on that front uh
you know yes absolutely in terms of
holding the social media companies
responsible yes I am the top Republican
on the consumer protection data security
bill and we are indeed we have spent the
last two years working on social media
and governance and how they protect
individuals and Children online how they
censor and how they push forward
information how sometimes they push
forward products that are fraudulent
products so we're going to continue that
emphasis I've only got one more for you
I'm going to make it real easy for you I
know you're not in the middle of a
re-election campaign yourself but uh
what's your stump speech for for people
to be hopeful for America because I
think people are between the censorship
and getting post covid and just the
General State of sort of political
craziness I think people are just
looking for a kind of positive message
that's that's how I try to do my show
every day you know when you go when you
go back and you look at our founding
documents uh there is that
um that encouragement that we the people
should be the people and people is with
a capital P that is the regard with
which our Founders held the people of
this country looking at it as a country
that is indeed blessed and endowed by
God in individuals that are endowed with
these inalienable right and it is up to
us to exercise and protect and defend
those rights but it requires people to
be the people to take the responsibility
to hold their government to account and
it's so interesting to me I think you
can push people so far
and then they're going to say hey wait a
minute we've had it and we saw that with
the lockdowns and the mandates
and people saying no these are my rights
they're not government granted anything
they are my inalienable rights and I am
going to exercise my right and it is up
to you elected officials to reign in
this federal government Senator you are
a fine Senator and a fine woman and I
didn't even need to look at a dictionary
to figure out what that meant I
appreciate your time and I hope I hope
it's to see you maybe at the Ryman uh
sometime soon oh you got it any day
great always you are welcome in
Tennessee come see us thank you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell